the iconic areas of Brooklyn which were
showed up in early gameplay demos of the
division won't actually be included in
the game at launch according to Ubisoft
creative director Magnus Jansen told The
Examiner pattam clancy's the division we
are going with midtown Manhattan it's
because of the 121 recreation and the
way the pandemics happened basically
everything has been hit and there are no
more resources because everyone trying
to come out there's no more gasoline in
the cars there's no traffic you're on
foot chanson added that midtown
Manhattan will offer up a huge open
world and players can expect a deep
level of detail and density currently
being theorized that Brooklyn as well as
other boroughs like Queens the Bronx and
Staten Island may pop up in post-launch
DLC the divisions closed beta begins on
January 28 for xbox one and on January
29 for ps4 and PC you'll be able to pick
up the full game on march eight let me
know down in that comment box how you
feel about the missing brooklyn content
and stay tuned to gamespot for all the
latest
you